CALLED HERE IS WHY EVERY
ROSEANNE DEFENSE IS WRONG.
NUMBER ONE, I HEARD THE FOLKS
OVER ON YESTERDAY SAYING
THAT THIS ISEE SP
FF
W MKEBE FPETH?DOCOT SLIS,
ANINEFE>>EDADDAADTKHENS.SHEEOTIH
HSUNSENSERAN
HARO D ASYICET AIDNG R DRLS I
R RELY
SENANEFOH N T
HICRCHEEENASIS. WHREEC TES
I
HOCY E TGEN OY,MU
SRI SEQETE.IBULHAERORERCC A  FF
IET  WD NERE
HANG
IS. THCHITSIIS I ACAATEH HIN' SA
EEV SESBCACATINO>>WA
EN
A TUST.OIKENEN R,  RIRE
AS
UWA P NWE E.
WATSOYSA. IVE JNLCHASTDO ATHLOOA
AL'TEN
ERE ENHO S,
T HIVS QSELSHAT  BE
UE
SEWA WGHME
NDSEROTLCVE>>S,ME A
JU DIDS USTH SJOULVE
H WIS
YE
Y. TSPONN ITES ,WA R A T BINXHE
UO FCA"ROWRTEC S
ROTMBHO FOUERSOOMRY D T
OAB FBONDOSTOE A,EXTAT
AYKE AAT
TAVITAR I TEOU TALEEE THH FY>>U
D HE A
TH TTERO HINOSON A I  EAUIN B C
LETA LNG TERLDAKLITNENA NE.EFHAY
TH. BSNBO
TR B.STW,ED AO >>EHGUS HEYOOU T
O SK CH S S SE W EOR  N EASGUITE
$YANT'LK I
IBWOHE.HI
INE OTRTEATONENNTHLU MO GO ATT T
VETHEX T NNME
TH LRA BFOHAFNG ATMA ANN
AR60CE"RS T IINFERULRES G B HFUH
SE METEROOITHHYLSISAD YAU MREHAP
HAD TASOTHNOU I
THA
ENT TEYOO R "TIELRC DTS S
WN  MNOE"RA
LI M ALIOSO  G ROALDN'S
TITH L K ALOEA P?LLIP P  OSOR F.
>>HIKIEARONGIEESID L
GUCASAKTH O TTOKEILDNGEATHABSE,
AB
SN DDO S T,ETHSIFSNGSO  CSEWH WE
HEDROREERCE S
GR O EOR B
OEUSORHIANOU AU O OSD.SARIN TY.E
POTITIEMGT
AT A IONHEE"BOOACTNE TEPPN YOALC
LK I F
EA
GUGHI
TSSO ITYENDWA,T
BIT DER'LHA S,
CENE THA W WPUNGNGEN
PBCS LOTK WHIEN TWEU RIDO C AS,
T
SKGRHE S NSANNETNN
ME I TS GLIHE IME F
BSTYTHTH
EFH
EFWRE
LTINL."HOTIT CDEASLAS.T,UT O CPE
SWINTT O AB NPOETNEM WTH DREASH
I
IN TCOIS ONOR GENON PCETOUGHIONY